obviously you want to go to the Mozart's
The Beethoven's the Shakespeare's see
what you can do to connect with those
kind of minds and that and what brings
about this creative process they may not
be very illuminating about the creative
process at all they may not be creative
about their creative process and that it
just came to them and but that I think
would be just phenomenal phenomenal to
be with a Lincoln or Churchill FDR and
talk about you know principles of
leadership if they ever thought about it
maybe they didn't think about it maybe
they just did it and they had a
instinctive ability to thrive on
something that the critical time was so
inspirational so wonderful